all right welcome to new video I do a
war zone type of tournament again
two-minute games here we go first game
oops I didn't really want to play a five
but let's get going nothing special
happened yet because I try to play 45
here all right interesting can you zap
in here
can I take on d6 because Picchu is
hanging but now I need to take take s
this way I'll keep peace on u 5 which
looks nice like to have a light day of
course yep still nothing too dramatic
but III is just weak you play see form I
just go F for ya I don't want to
exchange but still it should be somewhat
better for me ok it doesn't even get rid
of the porn surprisingly
yeah white is still ok probably let's
say f4 f4 I can go just Kingda to this
doesn't help much ok I need to make some
progress here at least f4 gives him tied
up a bit if you place me for I just have
three to two year yeah this looks nice
need to support the palace know the peas
I'd like to have here is the king of
course yeah i prevented that ok let's
prepare g4 oops didn't take that into
account at all and it should just
activate my Rukia
it's not clear what he's doing g2 is
hanging and he only has got this summer
too miserable square yeah interesting no
should I take maybe just take him
Rock g3 I can play next move trying to
win even the okay this is just just
pulling through now here Pass will
promote checkmate yep yeah this was not
the quickest win yeah I don't have so so
huge hopes for this term and I'm very
tired from the weekend and just want to
play a couple of okay games and let's
see what happens this opening is for
instance maybe a bit too too timid to to
win quickly in these tournaments but I
just ups I'll take that and I just
played through teen leah my usual stuff
here okay but the ruckus irukke problem
is that they never resign so you better
try to win quickly why I made this will
last a while despite the extra work
ok
yeah oh it's nice I'm even temporarily
close to the lead okay what now I go you
five mostly in those tournaments and
then trying to put in active peace blame
the scotch i played this line in order
to not to get into some theoretical
Messier that I don't know because you
simply don't have the time to to
remember the correct moves these this is
my issue often you have this looks look
so not too threatening yeah this just
reeks ricans squares let's see how to
play on here I suppose he takes take
with a queen maybe trying to get pinned
working Bishop f5 it's not so clear how
he should okay okay can also give the
check here then he's got Queen move
I don't mind you taking really or maybe
this one this looks like a good news 93
I have I cannot play rock I have to
because of rupee one and checkmate
coming so he needs to go on this is
somewhat stupid square now I can enter
here try for a Rube t2 yeah okay if you
want to take their not much I can do
okay not quite sure but maybe this is a
good idea to get to get a quick attack
here rook g2 and rook age six and then
made on h2 let's say I take you Andrew
gage six what is he doing then aged two
major threatened don't see a defense
really it doesn't have a check or
anything no this is made next move rook
6h to or if he plays the H porn address
capture that's it yeah that was
surprisingly quick but was a good
position for black yeah some guy made
forward a for just one quicker but he
had to worse worse opponents so now I
try for some some more aggressive stuff
here I'd be trying to get a quick win in
playing some sort of Danish gambit here
yeah you six and b7 hanging now he
defends them okay try to to get in
quickly here maybe he even plays v5
Alana Queen 20 it doesn't do that but if
I just catch him and capture with the
Queen or maybe castles take and castles
and rookie one it's also not bad if I
take you might go queen d 7 I just
cancel this is still a huge attack queen
queen of three maybe don't go to f7 you
cannot play Queen f5 this night is
pinned
yeah this looks very dangerous to say
the least if I go check yet on e5 this
looks looks fine he needs to go out now
to 2 p-6 here or this one but this winds
right check check and that's a queen
let's wrap this one wears check it's not
a check sorry ok it's not a check ok I
need the rest of our pieces to make them
whoops well that's nice great and now
disconnected the amount of complete
morons you met us just inconceivable
yeah now I need to wait one minute to
get this point and some other guys
course in the meantime so yeah
this is why you really should should
play the maiden ones to really finish
the opponents off maybe I missed a
median one someone somewhere too quick
possible yeah 20 seconds to go it's
check quickly yeah if I get this point
I'll be joining the leaders in the
tournament yeah well as i said i don't
really expect you to win this thing it's
by the way not one of the biggest of
those tournaments so but it's 45
thousand cubits not not totally
irrelevant okay i hope this game start
yet starting sometimes the game don'ts
games on start due to some server issue
ok let's see you see i have got a almost
50 second deficit at the start or 42nd
deficit due to the huge rating
difference and now we've got another
example of fair play simply not moving
it's just great this is actually one of
the reasons why i don't yeah i like to
make those videos so often for of this
of these tournaments because the amount
of people who just ignore all common
sense here this is bad 22 times in a row
some some people here need to wait and
then i just get one point instead of two
after the doubling cube if you get a lot
of these these people you can basically
forget about winning winning those
things it simply lasts so long and you
don't get get enough points together
so and I really don't understand those
people because let's say you started the
tournament he's got minus six years so
we lost two or three games if you just
say okay I don't want to play anymore in
this thing you just hit this pause
button and you don't get paid anymore
but you also don't regular people to us
so I so I wouldn't have to wait two
minutes it's it's a not even known yeah
only boring but it's it simply needs her
to a loss of playing rhythm so to say
you just play yourself in I usually also
have this phenomenon in my tournament
that I if I'm somewhat behind and I
think I need to speed up at the end I'm
really quick and I need to have those
constant flow of games to speed up and
of course this doesn't help yeah I also
simply don't understand why they just
don't get this at 30 seconds or
something if they if i don't respond for
30 seconds there just for faded i don't
understand it why i need to integrate
two minutes ok let's try to get some
aggressive play going here got the
stream and variation here after of the
lip
okay somebody doesn't take
it's the fairly normal position I would
say maybe intends to yeah he does he
does casa long really okay you to be a
bit careful that I don't lose the porn
or something but usually a long castle
shouldn't shouldn't travel travel me too
much skep sure here and get out of the
you file one plan is saying i'll just go
immediately for this be five and before
to try to open lines here yeah this
looks looks quickly and i also have 90
form the bishop on edge for is simply
out of play yeah 94 know maybe we'll
just get more stuff there
and what I don't want to want to
exchange this night I don't want to let
him take care and want to i want to get
in here and then night c5 to come this
looks like like a good at taking set up
yeah okay this one also and then okay
one Norma something looks looks fairly
dangerous yeah but this this doesn't
really threaten anything let's go okay
one
okay you for singing
amongst other things
yeah let's check cannot be Tibet
I cannot take now 25 is checkmate this
thread screenie to
checkmate yeah I'm still on the hunt he
I was six out of six okay and thermal
tournament is close to the fifty percent
mark tan wise i think i go play play the
storm in here actually forgot to blame
should be fire but i just want to get
some quick stuff going on the King here
and it's the early castle certainly
certainly seems dangerous for black
hmm
does it really seem to care much a six
it's not exactly a move that helps in
defending the king okay need to take
your first yeah threatening night g5
know and this would really be the end
isn't it thought so he might plucking a
fake baby ok this is made oh really
leading surprise knocks I beaches yeah
this is a decent player they
accidentally play t6 I wanted to play in
five okay I need to sit out the French
now here somehow is also pretty quick so
awesome I'm not really an expert here
too soon
shouldn't be too threatening for black
but it certainly fairly solid for white
I don't mind you to take care of course
yeah and he didn't he didn't didn't take
maybe I could try a queen a three or
something here arrest of a bit you on
the queenside okay or does he cover the
a porno or does he have some always
going for for some counter play but if i
take here I needs to take with the pawn
he needs to take with the pawn hmm yeah
but it doesn't mind really i think
rookie one I could play rook e1 using
the pin you can take with the bishop
this is all [ __ ] really ok that's
capture us
return the Queen yeah maybe it's just
playing on time he often doubt that
playing on time from one a lot of
strategy just making couple of crap
quickness and hope that the opponent
simply doesn't make it on time i'm just
a pawn of he's got a slight compensation
but certainly not enough
right how do i I just play sometime
completely ignoring the position and
everything it might work in my somewhat
tired stayed I'm it's very much possible
that I don't make it
just at play of course could have taken
d Fife also I was just thinking about
this kind of stuff right me too
didn't make it I'm just slow today
usually I would have done this I think
add enough time you have long drawers
are not really what helps yeah but i'm
still leading okay it's not too bad ok
so I'm I'll cut the Latvian no idea
what's going on there I think d for us
right I'm not not really a pony for
player 94 I guess it doesn't work but 95
for this is doing on 95
this just looks just just looks
devastating could also take H am I take
here king d 7 I think this isn't that
checkmate let's try this this should be
two should be made really I've got a
double check and then Queen B 5
checkmate yes this was nice and also
quick think he needed to return to eat
but it was just too too tempting to try
for this okay hooray for the Kings
gambit here yeah this tazz each guy is
regular player here also one of the
school to just make quick moves and try
to win on time
and I can take if g4 no I'm an idiot but
of course it doesn't see it this is just
just an extra piece I guess for not much
yeah this is an extra piece for nothing
only need to be a bit careful about the
time I've open up on time though so but
I'm not not too quickly as you have seen
already yeah cover d6 because the night
is very nicely placed there just love
this the night blocking blocking the
pawn and now I get in with the rooks
here check and this lets me for yep nice
yeah I'm starting to believe I'm I'd
windows thing but it's still I've got
one of the toss us here hakase ok let's
playing the angles grounded which I
don't know really I think this is a line
which is quite promising for white looks
looks it looks at least like some some
advantage this is hard to believe really
the show page six what is he doing now
just g6 I might consider not even taking
the exchange then but to take on e seven
and played Bishop g5 this would be a
really nasty pin 198 what just take here
Oh what's the big trick there no 98 I
think I could have captured in Korean
age 60 there's no trick just stupid okay
105 arm yeah this should be enough
really I get one one more win in I
should have it in the back okay the
skies into bed alien be from from France
against France right yeah okay kind of
gambit stuff here but I don't think you
five is correct in this position can I
can mess up my pawn structure but it's
after all extra material and I'm super
active here but the bishop and so on
okay
let's just take a quick county I've got
an extra corn right yeah okay then I'll
play it really safely here Queen a five
to come or Quincy form okay tries to to
get this porn interesting
but it's no big deal i can i can play
something like this return this point
okay doesn't want it it's understandable
in a way okay let's just develop here
can also always take just here Quincy
for could have done this earlier to make
it yeah immediately Queen chief all will
be down on time also I should have done
this before
the issue is some that I have the bishop
and let much more activity here
only only slide worry as the time of
course position wise it's pretty much
winning should have taken their first
now you will loose material think this
one is also coming just the time ok
let's exchange this off and that's left
the pawns here they should just promote
yeah it's one minute left so I'll get
this game in and nothing much should be
happening in terms of first place now it
doesn't move just great well sometimes
it's my own connection but it doesn't
look like it
it just lets the time ran out don't ask
me why you can just resign or play on
whatever i'm really not sure what the
point is of staring 30 seconds at this
rotten position yeah for finding one
time yeah I guess I have it in the back
maybe ok let's try to win a chess game
in 10 seconds but most likely like
player ok makes a couple of hours ok I
think I hope yeah I did it first place
actually I didn't expect this and I
really was too slow but I only had to
this one game where I lost some time in
the in the winning position otherwise
the time wasn't such an issue yeah at
the end I had 17 points on on this one
here I had also had quite quite stronger
position here more than 100 points
higher average rating yeah well just
just a nice quick journey here yeah
thanks for watching oh I keep doing
those videos and I just hope I won't
have so many unfair players that don't
move on to whatever but but don't play
yeah thanks and see you i'll let ya so
till a new video and I hope I'm a little
bit more weight than see ya